All right, so in creating your
Hello World Swift iOS app in Xcode,
let's go to File, New, and Project.
We're going to select Single View
Application, we're going to make sure we
have the application section
selected under iOS and click Next.
We're going to type in
the name of our product.
Now this iOS app is your first iOS app,
let's call it PitchPerfect.
You can put in whatever organization
name you would like and
identifier we're going to
cover that in a little bit.
Make sure the language selected is
Swift, that it's set to Universal,
and you don't need to
use Core Data right now.
We're going to use it
in a later project.
With that, click Next.
Select a location that
you'd like to put it.
For me here I'm just going to
put it straight in the Desktop.
Go ahead and click Create.
Xcode will now create a new iOS
app called PitchPerfect and
automatically create some needed
files and settings for you.
Here, you can see the iOS app that Xcode
has automatically created for you.
It has an AppDelegate class that will
listen to system events such as being
called when your app starts,
when you get a memory warning, and
when your app is sent to the background.
There is also a view controller and
an empty view.
We'll add more to those soon.
For now you can add a single
line into the app delegate to
a function that gets called
when the app launches called
applicationDidFinishLaunchingWithOpti-
ons.
This one line of code will print
out Hello World to the console.
So here we are here, and
we can see that in green Xcode
has highlighted comments for us.
And this function that we're talking
about here is the one where we want to
add a line.
In the AppDelegate,
inside the application
didFinishLaunchingWithOptions functions
we're going to add the line,
print("Hello world").
Now if you click the Run button
right up here on the top left,
we're actually going to run
this in the iPhone simulator.
You can see our brand new app
showing an all white background.
In the console you see
the words Hello World.
Five minutes and
you've already created an iOS app.
Although it won't win any
Apple design awards just yet.
We're going to work to build it and
improve it throughout this course.
First let's take a closer look at Xcode.